we're here in the streets of New York
asking people do they like the New York
Jets or not let's see what happens
he ain't gotta be up in the halls -
rabbit rabbit whooping - Kaufman talks
about ownership and average safety every
Texas out there beverage I need three
fire videos a day for Instagram
I'm going to try to do more - my phone
camera on the vlog the rocks pushing it
that is awesome ah and get raucous boss
right shut up
very [ __ ] meta
literally the worst moments of my life
is watching daily be such a waste of
time but got to make sure these guys
don't [ __ ] I don't need iris or
Justin slipping something in by accident
get Rock you're finally there trusting
someone third time's a charm gonna bring
it hard to make ten million to make
fifty mil I'm trying buy the New York
Jets everything you could assist you
want about it yeah if you've been there
every year then have motivation 105 1 I
love you Justin
Garvey what a moment everything you are
going to having you and all of the paint
over 200 years old and be having me
everything's good how are you he's a
little man he's making money he's all
good little slime is I'm [ __ ] fire he
wasn't a hustle died down I say Godric
look I mean look either you give a [ __ ]
I'll be that even yet I forgot right
good perfect either you give a [ __ ]
about what other people think or you
don't the curve balls that are thrown at
life are either insular or you care
about what other people think so if bad
things are happening usually people
break down because they're worried about
what their friends thinks what their mom
thinks what their aunt thinks what the
market thinks when bad things have
happened to me or when I see other
people that I've seen when when bad
things happen they go inside themselves
and they just calibrate it with
themselves so I listen life's going to
only throw you curveballs you know you
could be on top of the world the next
day it's over and so I think it's
basically about how you think I
guarantee the reason you are even asking
that question is you care too much what
other people think
[Music]
here let me Nina there go go go
currently what apps you use the most
frequently probably Instagram you know
like I just follow the attention and at
the end of the day Instagram is where
people are act but let me drop a little
knowledge here snapchats sneaky like
everybody's kind of famous ghost and I'm
getting more than ever on there truth is
snapchat Facebook Twitter Instagram
YouTube all of it anything I don't know
it's a better job in that problem there
that's ok you do so much any better than
I do I want you to realize the problem
is that the problem isn't the other
person the problem is that you're
[ __ ] trying to take like let me judge
it why'd you small talk me I'll tell you
why small talk to you you can't always
come and ask in first year without
bringing any valley victors he wants to
think about you know the need like for
me that we you know why I love everybody
you honestly know why like everybody
know because I don't [ __ ] need
anything
faster than anybody so building
disappoints me I don't judge anything of
course I want them to win but more
dearly I don't want anything to come
back right that's the [ __ ] thing it's
interesting one of the things that
excites me most about Boehner talent is
helping musicians helping people that
have tons of influence make a far
greater impact and yet show the behind
the scenes lesson I mean they get
celebrities for the flashy stuff when in
reality the reason that they've got to
that stage is because they do what
happen to behind it it's why do daily be
like I love my episodes that are boring
right or the same [ __ ] yeah cuz that's a
[ __ ] punch line yeah yeah like the
thing that excites me about daily be
yeah is not you listen there's two
things there's many things that excite
me it'll be so fun to look back when I'm
59 63 72 be like oh I ran into Malcolm
back then like you know like this
watching this will be fun but what's way
more fun is the body of work yeah when
episode 5000 basically looks like
episode 219 that's when people can be
like [ __ ] yeah stress you know it's the
studio time right it's the snap it's a
repetition it's the meeting after
meeting after meeting after meeting
after meeting
pattern recognition refining pattern
recognition refining pattern recognition
refining getting punched in the mouth
swallowing that blood getting punched
enough swallowing that blood finding
your opening finding that breakthrough
being right being wrong to the process
and nobody's really documented the
process at the scale that I'm thinking
about accomplishing right look at that
guy's okay except I got it oh okay yeah
let's go like a fired up
have you been so confuse you walk right
out your shoes and to the ghetto slows
the blast Avenue from parts where are my
folks applause they kept a bruise to
keep the jiggle that they crazy with
every question where I mean I'm laughing
truckzilla ejecting for the fortune J
Dilla the Pan Am is novice obtaining
knowledge I will teach it to me there
were critical fan time to bring the shot
of the day gig I ordered right here
remember this morning hey long time
right now this is gonna be a freshman
year are you [ __ ] her pants
you're good I really thought that was a
scariest jump I thought the scariest
jump was junior high to high school that
that's more than any jump ever that
seemed like the craziest one yeah the
older siblings I was the first and like
from of immigrants I good enough huh
yeah all right good all right I'm gonna
figure out what I'm gonna do
I'll be back I won't leave you guys
hanging gonna get all my focus of blood
the chemicals the kings that she goes
that they pray I mean it's just let that
go into a meeting I mean every night
I'm basically happen mom we're in the
streets of New York asking people to
like the New York Jets or not let's see
what happens
I don't want to bother people it's so
funny
so we're protected I love my simple
black I'm calling the coolest brother
freeze the DPP ha I got a secret the key
but no ghost a spinnaker then I could
cover help haven't got dirt I'm a
prodigy recipe that they gave the gloves
these are my brilliant affiliates they
don't be anxious
don't let Hank when you promote an
intern post visual to the end consumer
do they see anything that is yeah yes
officer but what about people that see
it organic No so DUI follows me and we
promote if he saw it as a motive correct
but not if you didn't love it on the on
a negative front the my push
notifications isn't working the
60-second Club is not working but that's
happened once or twice before meaning
they're not getting notification yeah I
can notice the notifications are always
sort of delayed though no right now it's
like not at all
[Music]
but you're right I mean Google's entire
business is at stake every single person
in here is going to search through voice
before they die
every single person very years old only
searches through voice one every five
searches on Google on voice according to
Google according to Google who has risk
of losing their business to report that
number HP oh yeah there's a mix-up okay
three to four
okay listen 320 okay time Roman a right
over there they'll take me yeah
okay you should go now okay I have to go
to H be others mixed up over here okay
I'll be back in like an hour
hey I ran into your boyfriend yeah such
a nice guy so random
what's that [ __ ] do you ah the wall
footage forget it
straight to the fact that do this for
Mama
make it like be such a little thing to
do you know hi
how are you all the way we really go for
us you better be you nominally but if
you are talking about killing me and
I'll just about the late timing is
everything
yeah
[Music]
to the brain
I'll help you yes okay
but I have thank you crap
baby that's my just my time doing my
time yes master
that's my back yeah no I think I'm
trying to do the market where my dad did
for me at for Tina right I was on my way
I would have been the worst of the bunch
I mean the Alpha worst I'd be the number
one worst I probably make it 304 to
really know zero announces bad like all
from the worst and the ones that could
never and he saved me
right
so I'm impacting you in that year right
and if you stay the course
it'll get to a really interesting place
you know what the best part is for guys
like us we still have that ability to
sell once you deploy it against
something you truly believe all the way
it just compounds at a level that
becomes so much greater legacy
[Music]
post up and nipped open up first I mean
this yeah that's right I want you on the
blog you have to inspire the next
generation that's generationally look at
me they don't want to be hired by me hi
I'm inspired by you you're an AFC East
football team that inspires me I wonder
what you're so much better
haha my team's not gonna win a single
[ __ ] game this year
my school is out it's exactly knock you
out of the playoffs aphorism how are you
you're really spinning a spinner that
excites us you you're free you know what
I love about you do you make slime - do
you know about that trend yes I love you
mama
thank you so when they come it's not a
swamp in between Oh Rocco what do you
want to be mister you really want to see
them all right
well we're looking community you just
said live then I now you've not even
said a lot give me something
okay what else you want to you want to
see me buy the Jets don't you that's
important to you well listen 20 years
can you do it yeah you you're you really
just pissed me to [ __ ] oh okay all right
what else I'm definitely doing in 19 now
yeah yeah
all right text me uh how long you there
the whole weekend breaking news ages
having a baby so that's the end of this
show rated level 99 in the 2002 pocket
from the east side they can eat survive
with the crew phantom ness rail
what you are the my plan what you are
them up